a devoted wife and mother a doting
grandmother Joyce was a wonderful woman
this is Claire one of Joyce's oldest
friends ever College together
Howard
I'm gonna kill you
now that she's gone I want to do it this
weekend
Evelyn I need to talk to you about what
I told him I was gonna kill him
I could chat it's been four and a half
decades feels like it was yesterday you
were delusional she told me you were
cruel
so what's the plan Scarface I'm gonna
buy a gun it was cute very wanna hold it
and I'm gonna take it to the wake
how's the recoil
I'm not gonna lie it has a little kick
well darn it we tried do you have any
poison I have a cyanide pill in case I'm
captured by the enemy you can have it
I want you to tell the truth I am
shocked shocked by your utter
selfishness you blame me for what
happened in your own marriage I think
you were not built for happiness I mean
you're in what my other murder canceled
this week so I've got
missed you you had my number well you
had my number so we're both lousy
friends
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]